Welcome back.
I want to let you realize that the Peloponnesian War is over.
What.
A RELIEF.
Twenty seven bitter years but it's just one of those times through history that
you discover no sooner is it over than another kind of trouble starts.
And of course as you know the whole course has been filled with that kind of
trouble and it will continue that way right to the end.
Well you remember what the Spartans allegedly went to war about back there in
431.
They were going to free the Greeks and the irony of that is really quite
extraordinary remember a.
Xenophon ends his tale of the end of the Peloponnesian War How the Spartans and
their people were all tearing down the walls of Athens to the music of flute
girls and everybody thinking or it seemed.
I forget exactly how he puts it that this represented the beginning of freedom
for the Greeks.
Well of course he was writing this years later and he knew perfectly well that
was an illusion because Spartan power which had grown to an unprecedented degree
in the course of the war now presented the Spartans with problems and
opportunity.
You know I think that's a it's a very important thing to understand and I think
not enough people do.
Power has a certain life of its own the capacity to be able to do something
without somebody preventing you makes you think about what you might do in ways
that you never thought about before when you didn't have the power to do it.
And of course this is what happens to the Spartans.
They find themselves presented with choices that they could take.
How would they conduct themselves and their state and how were they to try to
arrange the structure of states in the Greek world and including their relations
to Persia.
Because they really had enough power to be able to think of different things
they might do the logic of the situation
presented really three possibilities they could of course do what they had done
much of the time before the fifth century namely to confine themselves to the
Peloponnese is to maintain their control the Peloponnesian league and basically
not to get involved in anything outside the Peloponnesian much recommended that
in Spartan tradition it meant that the hell out problem which was always on
their minds something they couldn't forget.
They were desperately outnumbered at all times by people who hated them and whom
they lived off.
So the notion of leaving with an army from the Peloponnesian from the
Peloponnese is at any time was always a questionable proposition even though
sometimes it was necessary.
And as we shall see changes had taken place in Sparta in the course of the
Peloponnesian War of which I suppose the most important was the appearance in
the hands of the Spartans of a good deal of money which was made available by
the Persians for wartime purposes but both in the doing in the collecting of
that money and also in the taking of many cities away from the Athenians very
prosperous cities the Spartans also gained a great deal of booty.
So for the first time there were lots of Spartans who had lots of money and of
course as you know not only was that not a characteristic feature of Spartan
society normally was forbidden.
The laws in Sparta did not permit coins.
The closest thing to coins were these fistfuls of iron spits which don't get you
very far and don't buy very much.
It was.
And see the point is that the presence of that kind of wealth and really no no
traditional way of coping with it meant that there were other uncertainties.
Now that the opportunities that various Spartans fell so anyway.
The idea of staying in the Peloponnese is.
Certainly appeal to many Spartans because they feared that involvement outside
the Spartan world and certainly they fear the arrival of money which would be
necessary as they became outside to live at least to be engaged outside that
world would undermine those traditions which they valued so much which were part
of their identity living according to the laws of life Kirkus war was what it
meant to be a Spartan and made you feel superior to other people so there was a
feeling of danger in the minds of the conservative Spartans who would have
preferred that.
But of course there was the other possibility that the Spartans could use this
newfound power.
And I suppose the money that went with it to
govern the things and maybe to exploit opportunities outside the Peloponnese and
that choice also could be divided up into two at the extreme.
The Spartans had it in their power to contest control of the entire Greek world
in the in the east.
I mean I'm leaving out as we always do Western Greeks who live in Italy in
Sicily except when they get involved in the main theater in the Aegean.
But the Spartans could have and some Spartans did want to contest control of the
Aegean and of the coast of Asia Minor and of the hill a spot in the waters
beyond with the Persians but would otherwise have controlled them now that the
Athenians were out of the way.
This would require money but it would also make money available and of course it
would take power but it would also produce more power in a certain sense
Spartans who took this point of view had it in mind to take the place of Athens
as the great imperial power in the Aegean.
And beyond that was a possibility and we know for sure that some Spartans in the
chief figure here was like Sandor the great general admiral who had been
responsible for winning the war.
We know for sure that he and others around him like that idea and sought to
pursue it.
But they were not alone in that opinion.
And then there's a third possibility that the Spartans had.
And although we know the ancient sources don't tell us that any Spartan leader
specifically had this in mind the sheer logic of it suggests that some of them
must have thought this was a bad idea and certainly some of the Spartan actions
suggests that they were pursuing such or tried to pursue such a policy that was.
Not to be confined to the Peloponnese but also not to engage in this grand or
you might even say grandiose plan of supplanting the Spartans of the Athenians
which would include necessarily somewhere down the road conflict with the great
Persian empire.
Of course the great Persian empire didn't seem so scary as it had at one time in
the past.
Remember the Athenians had defeated the Persians first of all the Greeks had
done that back and for 80 479.
But even so ever since then the Athenians had repeatedly defeated the Persians
over and over again.
So they weren't anything like the scary thing they had been at the beginning of
the century.
But in any case you'd have to take that on.
And many a Spartan would have been deterred by that prospect.
And again by the prospect of having to have a fleet because there was no way to
pursue this third policy without having a fleet that began to approach the power
of the Athenian fleet when it had been strong.
Well what did that mean.
It meant using not the traditional Spartan military advantage hop like soldiers
fighting infantry battles but also rowers and expert naval people.
I don't have the time to go into a detailed account of how naval warfare was
carried on in the Greek world.
But it's easy to forget that in addition to the rowers of whom there were one
hundred and seventy in each tri RIM who made who were the engine in the sense
they made the thing move and officers and something and usually at least ten or
so Marines who could be landed for behaving like hop lights on lamp in addition
to them they were critically skilled people who made all the difference in the
world.
And whether you won or lost in these naval battles who were well Whoa they were
sort of like Chief Petty Officer is if you think about it.
Well master sergeants in the Army professionals who were very whose very great
skills are critical for the functioning of the larger army.
The Greek word for the most important of these was Cuban innate tastes which
means steers men.
They were that and they were more than that by the way.
It's a very nice word because our word.
All the words that have to do with Governor government govern all derive
ultimately from the Cuba natives.
So
this would have meant that all kinds of people who were not Sparta Yates would
be critical for the success of such a commission of the overseas type and so
many a Spartan felt that was too much of a derangement of Spartan life and
didn't like it for that reason but you could still be in favor of a middle
policy which would mean extending Spartan power or maintaining Spartan power on
the Greek mainland outside the Peloponnese and there were certain things that
recommended that
for one thing the
Athens had been knocked out as a main power in central Greece.
And that meant it had been demonstrated in the course of the war that it meant
it.
That seems the dominant power and b o shop had already grown to considerable
power had developed a degree of independence which allowed the three bands to
challenge the Spartans frequently and to.
And there was a very real chance that Thebes would become and would seek to
become elite at least the power of the first rank at least somebody who could
sit equally at the table with the Spartans rather than subordinate to them and
the fear that some Spartans surely had was that if the Spartans simply stayed in
the Peloponnese as Thebes would become the master of Attica which was a neighbor
of Thebes as well as of central Greece as a whole and suddenly they would become
a real menace to the Spartans and indeed down the road if you go far enough.
That's exactly what did happen.
So that would be the case.
Well we need to be establish ourselves on mainland Greece as they hedgerow mons
the Masters.
If not I shouldn't say mass ahead Romans means leaders.
There is always a conflict there too when you have a power which is superior to
that of the other states.
But you don't conquer them.
The question is do you want to be relate to them as the Greeks would have said
as a hedge and Mon meaning a leader which implies a degree of voluntary
cooperation.
Or do you want to dominate which means mastery and the Spartans disagreed among
themselves as to what was necessary even if you were going to take that path.
But these three routes were theoretically and I think as matter of fact.
Really things that the Spartans argued about and there was a certain amount of
moving back and forth as the Spartans shifted from one to the other as different
individuals gained influence and circumstances change.
It's easy to.
To death to designate at least two of the factions and I'm I'm inclined to think
there were three that can be identified and identified with people the most
aggressive overseas let's conquer and control everything in the Aegean like
Sandor is clearly the leader of that faction
let's stay in the Peloponnese sis and stay out of.
Inter state rivalries and competitions and just go back to our old ways.
Appears to have been led by the king Pao seniors and there's another king ages
and he is the one it's unclear it's not can't be confident that he represented a
third faction but I think there's some possibility that he did and that that was
the faction that wanted to limit Spartan power influence control to the mainland
of Greece and not to go to sea and there were great arguments against the lie
Sandor approach.
For one thing the number of Spartans was pretty small to control too vast a
territory.
We can't be sure how many there were by now but it pretty it's pretty well
agreed that in the middle of the Peloponnesian War there was something like
thirty five hundred Sparta eights.
Only that many and the figure continues to go down by the time we get to the
decisive battle of Luke tra that defeats Sparta.
Finally in three seventy one there is perhaps about a thousand Sparta eights.
Well how do you run an empire.
Forget about how you conquer one how do you run one with that kind of population
and also of course the Spartans had traditionally not been a naval power and had
done very poorly at sea compared to the Athenians at least.
And it was open it was an open question how well they would do against the
forces that serve the Persian king at sea.
The fact was too that they had no experience with
money and money was a critical part of maintaining such an empire as the unions
could tell them.
And everything in the spartan tradition was based on land power.
Now we can overestimate that.
After all the Spartans had been sending fleets out to sea throughout the
Peloponnesian War in the last part of the war they won two important battles of
which the final battle was critical.
The battle of egos pot of money.
But if you really look at the whole story it's not at all clear that the
Spartans ever developed the kind of system that would produce a navy that would
year after year after year have the capacity to dominate the sea.
So that was a practical limitation.
Well anyway however that might be the man of the hour.
And for all 4 was like Sandor the great victor of the Peloponnesian War and it
was his policy was the extreme policy that lets conquer at all policy.
His policy was very much a personal policy and here.
The personal is very important the fact that like Sandow was who he was made a
very great deal of difference by Sandor was not a pure legitimate Sparta 8.
He was what the Spartans called a most Moxie was a technically a bastard.
That means he had a Spartan father and non Spartan mother.
Typically such women were.
What but it had been Hellas but.
In any case he was brought up nonetheless as a spartan but not as his 48 and how
to put these pieces together is very hard to know.
But he did as a few others like him in the last years of the war rose to be a
general and the very best general of all and the man who was put in command of
the forces.
But he was a man of extraordinary ambition and the ancient writers tell us that
he had developed the notion of actually bringing about a revolution in Sparta
and changing the constitution in such a way that would allow him to become
effectively the ruler of Sparta and the kings the traditional kings who were
born to the purple to be put aside.
Well if he was going to do anything like that even if he was only going to try
to retain the position he had achieved of tremendous influence and power he
would need to have a command.
He would need to have money.
He would need to have supporters of every kind and his policy therefore for
Sparta was very much a policy that fit the needs of lies Sandor
wherever he liberated a city in Asia Minor which had been.
Under the Athenian Empire part of the Athenian Empire.
He established a different kind of government.
It consisted of ten men chosen from the local people who were friendly to him
who were reliant on him his people his puppets if you will the the name for
these establishments was deck car keys.
Rules of ten men of ten.
Groups of ten and they were his people and to make sure that they were safe.
He is stout.
He would.
He placed a Spartan Garrison or at least a Peloponnesian garrison in that city
led by a Spartan commander called a harm most it comes from the same word from
which we get harmony.
Somebody who preserved order who was the the military commander of that region.
All of these people the harm most the deck clerks were all his creatures not
anybody who had any independent power or influence simply his people who did the
job for him.
And liberators of the Greeks as they had claimed to be like Sanford did not
abandon collecting the money from these cities that he had allegedly liberated
at the same amount apparently that they had they had given the Athenians because
our sources tell us that the Spartans were collecting a thousand talons a year
from the newly discovered newly acquired empire which is something like what the
Athenians got from it.
So.
All of that is in place this Spartan newly founded Spartan empire was different
from the Athenian Empire in a variety of ways.
Remember that you've seen an empire it started out as a voluntary association
with a very clear common purpose to liberate those Greeks who are still under
Persian rule and to preserve their freedom from their Persian neighbors and
former conquerors and on the other hand the this new empire underlies center had
no purpose.
And it was not voluntary in any shape manner or form.
It was thoroughly compulsory.
I think it's fair to say that the Spartans had simply betrayed the Asiatic
Greeks whom they had engaged in the rebellion against the Athenians and
kept instead of liberating them put them under Spartan rule and in many cases
frequently these governments established by the light center were tyrannical and
rapacious in which these governors and the harmless and so on basically stole
what they could from the natives.
This is apart from the official payments they made to the Spartans.
They enriched these lice Sandrine creatures
as one of our rights so ancient sources rights to the will of any Spartan was
regarded as law in the subjects cities.
It is clear from all the ancient writers that the Spartans were not
easy people in their dealings with other Greeks everything in their tradition
made them feel superior to other Greeks and they didn't mind acting in that way.
You remember the stories of how it was that the Athenian Empire was founded or
rather the deal in league the Spartans had so alienated all the Greeks in that
region by the way they treated them that they were glad to send the Spartans
away and replace them by the Athenians who did not treat them that way.
At least they didn't do it for some years before they develop into an empire.
So
this was another problem Spartans were not good at this job.
But at the beginning what was decisive was like Sandy.
He was at the height of his power and influence and I guess it's fair to say he
reached heights that no mortal ever had reached in the Greek world.
The oligarchs whom he had restored to power in Samos loved him so much and we're
so grateful for what he had done that they held religious ceremonies on the
island and literally worshipped like Sandor as a god.
This is the first time in Greek history that anybody had received such
treatment.
On the one hand this elevated his influence and power.
Everybody wondered at him and so on.
On the other hand it presented a problem because you can imagine how that went
down among the aristocrats of Sparta.
And most particularly with the Kings of Sparta you see that this I use a
technical term not a street curse word.
This bastard
was now being worshipped as a god.
And of course that kind of eminence was unheard of for a non King in the spartan
world.
So that had all kinds of trouble down the road.
And he was as ambitious as he could be and it was as obvious as it could be.
So there was jealousy and resentment and fear at Sparta that something bad was
going to happen to the Spartan way of life to the Spartan constitution and pop
seniors and his traditionalists biding their time for the opportunity to to put
a spike into this development.
There were other things that were flowing from what I've already described that
were threatening the traditional character of Spartan life.
This money of course allowed for corruption.
Now people who had money could buy people's support could buy people's
help in their own endeavors for influence and power in Sparta.
One of the things we hear about that most scholars would like to place in this
period and it seems reasonable to me.
Was a new law about inheritance.
It's the law of Epictetus.
He's the man who proposed it.
It used to be that inheritance automatically went to in a certain direction.
Nobody had any choice.
You couldn't make out a will and leave it to anybody you liked.
It went through the family according to a certain pattern.
The law of appetite has changed that you now could write a will and select your
successors however you wished your inheritance.
Excuse me.
That meant that
there were ways you could work around that so as to bind somebody right.
While you were still alive if you wrote somebody into your will you were in
effect giving him money after you died.
So meanwhile he could serve you and be your political supporter.
That was happening and people who had been raised the Spartans and expected to
inherit their father's property would sometimes find that they had been cut out.
And now they were Sparta eights by birth but they lacked the necessary wealth
necessary land to provide for their meals at the common mess and so they could
no longer be Sparta eights in the full sense and the term was discovered for
them.
They were called who put mayonnaise which means inferiors and some of the guys
who rose to power late in the Peloponnesian War as generals because they were
just good at it came from some such class.
So you have a variety of Spartans who are important who are not harlots who are
not people you can just do what you want to.
They play a significant role in society but there they don't have the position
of honor.
The position of belonging that was necessary and these were disruptive and
troubling developments in the spartan state.
There we get a clue about this and 398.
We hear about the planning of a revolution in the city a man by the name of
Kennedy on who was one of these ships of mayonnaise and
was planning to have an uprising in which they would kill lots of Spartans and
set up a new regime that would give room to the people who were outsiders.
Well the plot was prevented because one of the people that Kennedy approached
told the story to Spartan magistrates and the plot was averted.
But he told the to the story he told was this he was standing one day in the
Agora in Sparta and Kinison approached him and he said Look around you he said.
How many how many Sparta aides do you see.
Well the answer was forty he said and how many people are there around here who
are not Sparta.
And he said about 4000.
He was talking about hippo mayonnaise Nerio Damo days various other subspecies
but also how lots and also Perry oi oi.
And said Canada on to the man he was trying to recruit these 4000 as regards the
Spartans would gladly eat them raw
so his message was is why don't we have a little revolution.
Well yeah the answer was he was forestalled but it does tell you that the
situation had become sufficiently dangerous that such a possibility existed.
So there is Sparta coping with these various problems and trying to decide how
to handle their future.
And I'd like to shift the scene now to Athens Athens which had been the greatest
empire that the Greeks had ever seen had been reduced now to total defeat
absolutely at the mercy of the Spartans and indeed the Athenians feared and
certainly had reason to fear that the same fate they had visited upon some
states that had defied them and there were two that fit the category I'm about
to mention me lost the island that was conquered by the Athenians and efficient
cities describes how the Athenians spoke to them in the famous million dialogue
and also a place that
the not most people don't remember but another town and race in both places the
Athenians killed all the adult males on the island when they finally put an end
to the siege and sold the women and children into slavery.
See Athenians had every reason to fear that that might be what happened to them
as a matter of fact.
Cormorants and thieves in the conference they had at the end of the war said
let's do that
Saban's especially said let's turn Attica into pasture land.
Well the Spartans didn't do it.
And the main reason they gave was well it would be wrong to treat such a people
that way such a people who helped us in such a critical way as our partner
against the Persians when we won our freedom.
Well if you can believe that you can believe anything more to the point I think
was their fear that if they did destroy Attica.
I mean the the the the houses and the people and all that what would happen is
this would really be a vacuum a vacuum of people of everything else and
certainly a vacuum of power and it wouldn't stay that way very long.
Thieves and it's ocean subordinates would come in and occupy it and that was not
a desirable thing.
And so the Spartans didn't do that.
Instead with lice sand they're very much in charge of the settlement that was
going to be imposed on the Athenians they placed in power a small group of.
Oligarchic Athenians just as by the way he had the same kind of people in the
rest of the Empire but not ten.
Athens was a very big place.
It turned out that there were to be 30 of these new rulers of Attica all of whom
had to meet the criterion of being acceptable to lie Sandor and the leaders of
which the really important top gun was a man by the name of Christy as a
nobleman who had participated in democracy.
But it turned very sharply against it.
He was a brilliant man.
Apparently he had been trained by the great red attrition and sophist Gort
Gheorghe yes.
And he was also in the circle of Socrates along with Plato and Xenophon and
various other bright young men of the upper classes in Athens.
And he was a poet an orator himself a philosopher and so on.
He had and some of his.
Fragments of some of his works remain for us to look at
but one thing that he was by for or for was a bitter enemy of the democracy.
He had been exiled or had voluntarily taken exile in order to get away from the
democracy and he was determined now that there should be no democracy in Athens
does this say a word about that for a moment.
It was an easy point of view to arrive at four or four people who were not
friendly to democracy could simply point to the fact that the democracy had just
lost this great war and nobody could really understand how that had happened
given the great power of Athens and of course it was easy to point to the great
event that turned the tide against Athens the Sicilian expedition and to say
this was an idiotic idea and it was exactly the kind of idiotic idea that a
democracy would come up with and so that democracy itself was seen to be not
just
how can I put but I was gonna say.
Let me say it was seen to be inherently wicked because it violated what seemed
to be the truth about human beings and which was very much a part of all Greek
tradition from the first time we hear about it in Homer until well forever which
was contrary to the principle of democracy which is that all men adult male
citizens are equal in some very fundamental way or should be was the the
contrary view which had much greater support in Greek tradition that no men were
in fact divided into different kinds of people.
And in fact the Greeks thought a division into two kinds was the right kind.
The most important kind.
A division between the high and the low between the good and the bad between the
noble and the base.
And each of those pairs.
They were all the same people you're you're rich you're wise you're well born or
I should say you're rich and well born therefore you're wise or you are not and
if you're not you're obviously not equal to the other guys and therefore you
shouldn't have anything to do with ruling anybody.
So that was the basic widespread view of what was natural in the Greek world.
Now you add to that that they have just lost this terrible war and you could
point to what seemed to you to be both a wickedness and foolishness.
How in the world could anybody think democracy was a good thing after that.
Lest you think there's is something special about that that's such a
characteristic of the human race when whenever you have a great war and if you
have two different kinds of political systems vying with each other winning has
an amazing effect on what people think.
So that it was the take the first world war when the it's let me back up.
Yeah.
No let me back up let me just say that those countries who lost the war were
very open to the idea that whatever they typically had been monarchies and so
on.
But they had been rather relatively speaking liberal monarchies they had become.
Legislatures and elections and things like that.
And what came to be seen that was came to be seen as a losing proposition.
And so fascism of one sort or another took root across Europe in states that had
had that misfortune and that it was felt that success or failure had to do with
the rightness of the wrongness of wisdom of the foolishness of the kinds of
arrangements that you had.
And then when.
While the Soviet Union was powerful and expanding around the world it was
expanding and part along with the idea of communism which was thought in the
circles where it succeeded to be superior to the competition and observe that
when the Soviet Union finally collapsed.
There are maybe communists around the world they know but they don't admit it.
I mean they call themselves something else.
The idea has been discredited by success of the competition by failure of that
thing.
So it's a phenomenon that is not amazing all this looks like the earliest
example I think that we know.
So
critics.
In any case was determined that Athens in the future would not be a democracy
and in fact it looks like he was very much taken again.
This is typical with the with the virtues of Sparta because Sparta had won the
war.
So it's easy to say the characteristics that the Spartans stayed had must be
good ones because they can do the most critical thing that a state can do win in
competition with the other states.
So he had in mind a very narrow oligarchy one scholar has suggested
he actually had in mind to establish in Athens the closest facsimile he could of
the Spartan constitution it could never be exactly the same.
But he was trying to do something like that that could be true but it was going
to be narrow a smallish number of people were going to control the city in fact.
Well let me back up before I'll come back to what I was about to say.
Now however when they set up to 30 to rule Athens in four or four.
It was apparent to people who could judge matters pretty sensibly that given
that Athens had been a democracy for over one hundred years that they would not
be easy to impose such a regime.
And that if you made the regime too narrow and too oligarchical you might find
yourself having trouble in keeping your your new regime in power.
So like Sander agreed to the idea of making
the 30 compose of 20 men who were critics as men very extreme oligarchs but
allowing ceramic kings and Athenian general who had flourished during the during
the democracy but who was very clearly not an old fashioned Democrat.
He had taken part in bringing about the oligarchic revolution of 400 in the year
for eleven
and win it again and that the group who'd made that revolution was divided in
something like the same way with the 30 would be.
That is to say extreme oligarchs and people like ceremonies whom I guess it's
fair to call moderate oligarchs although.
Oligarchs only I think in comparison with a thoroughgoing democracy.
Because if you ask the remedies what would be the right number of people in
Athens to participate in the government.
His answer was as it turned out 5000.
But he really wasn't interested in that number.
What he was interested in was the criteria for participation in government.
And that was to be a hop light to have the wealth necessary to fight in the
infantry for your city.
In a later census not too much later it was discovered that the number of men in
Athens who actually fit that description was not five thousand but nine thousand
at a time when the Athenian population of adult males was something like twenty
one thousand.
So that nine out nine out of twenty one would have been the people who
participated in the regime twelve out of the twenty one would have been too poor
for that would not have been allowed to participate.
Well that's not a democracy.
It is an oligarchy but it's a very broad oligarchy.
The word moderate I think applies.
So anyway so Romney's was to be given the opportunity to appoint nine others
besides himself.
So there were tens of Romanians 20 supporters of critics in the 30 and that was
to turn out to be a problem for the 30 as it had been for the 400 because when
ceramic he saw that his colleagues in the 400 were trying to establish a narrow
oligarchy he led an uprising that overthrew that oligarchy and ended up finally
restoring the democracy.
So that's the picture of what's going on in Athens.
But Athens of course was also inhabited at that time by all of the exiles who
had been sent into exile during the democracy and they were bitter enemies of
the Democrats at least lots of them.
So you had a kind of a.
Confrontation of different ideas and feelings.
That was a little unusual in Athens Athens had been a pretty easygoing place
before the war and even then throughout the war and to a large degree.
But now there were very hard divisions and very tense feelings between the
different groups
the 30 ruled between September of 4 0 4 and May of 400 and 3 just a matter of
months as it turned out although nobody of course knew who was going to be so
short when things got started
they established a council of five hundred.
Well that's the same number as the Athenian council.
But it was quite different.
It was made up of extreme oligarchs.
They were given judicial powers
men who were identified as sycophants and the Greek use of that term you
remember is people who made money out of denouncing people on false charges in
the courts and then winning payments as a result.
They were very widely unpopular even in the democracy.
And so the 30 began with an act that was not unpopular by putting to death all
the sycophants that they could find and identify.
But they also put to death.
This well-known leaders of the democracy people whom they knew would be their
political opponents.
So it was bloody from the first but it was only limited to a certain small
portion of the population
the 30.
I mean just to make the case that actually a man who makes this case a man named
Peter Krentz and he is an old yeller.
So we ought to give him credit he
if you look at the 30 what if you look at Sparta.
What what comes to your mind.
Did you ever see a ultimately in the course of these months the
30 limited citizenship active participation in the government of any kind to
only three thousand Athenians out of what would have been you know at least
21000 and probably more.
Only these had citizen rights.
The rest of the Athenians did not.
Well that's about it.
How many Spartans there were at this time in history.
Another thing they did was to at a certain point when life got tough they drove
from the city of Athens all those who were not part of the three thousand.
Well what do you call people like that who don't live in the capital city but
who live around Perry oi oi.
And so that's why Krantz suggests that this is not an accident that it's a
conscious effort to model the future Athenian state upon the great successful
admirable Spartan state wealth the remedies didn't like that.
This was far too narrow and far too troubling for the future truth.
The remedies.
And indeed he pointed out the contradiction you just how clever is this.
Here you are a minority in this state.
And instead of trying to bring on more people to make yourself stronger you're
driving out people and guaranteeing that you will have more people against you
than you have for you.
He's himself favourite as he had in the time of the 400.
He favored a hop like census anybody who could be a hop light could be a full
fledged citizen.
And I've told you about the numbers.
Well pretty soon the 30 became people objected to what the 30 was doing made
complaints and the 30 began to go after them.
At different times there one of the problems about talking about the 30 is that
it is not perfectly clear what is the chronology of events and I can't tell you
with certainty what happened but in what order these things happen.
But at some point in here the the 30 began to attack a larger group of Athenians
sometimes because they were seen to be political opponents or thought to be
political opponents or related to political opponents.
Sometimes when things got really bad when the 30 needed money they actually put
people to death just because they were rich so that they could take their money
away.
And this of course increased the amount of resistance on unhappiness so that
finally a small I want to emphasize small very small group of Athenians fled the
city and went into exile to neighboring cities.
And this is interesting I think an important.
The cities that were most receptive to these A.I..
30 A.I.
oligarchical anti Spartan
people the one that it was who received them most readily were Khan's Mega and
sees all enemies of Athens all enemies of democracy.
Why are they doing this.
The answer is they are both angry at the Spartans and I think fearful that the
Sparta that is a rising now will be a menace to their autonomy that they this
particular towns with angry about different things currents and saves remember
had wanted to destroy Athens entirely Spartans hadn't listened to them.
They all shared in the fighting and during that long war.
But they did not share equally and not enough to suit them in the booty that was
taken at the end of the war.
So there were grievances that these towns had and so they accepted this small
number of Athenians and the one town that was most important from this purpose
was thieves and in.
They were given a decent home.
The Spartans knowing about this sent out an order saying that no state should
give any
home to these exiles whereupon the seaborn regime at the moment voted that
anybody who didn't give help to these Athenians would be punished.
They simply were defying the Spartans on this question the leader the most
important of the leaders of this group of exiles.
It's fair to call them democratic exiles they wished to restore the old
democracy.
The most important man was thrashed the bullies who had been a general both his
best fighting had been done as an admiral during the latter part of the
Peloponnesian War.
He was present at all the great Athenian victories.
He was not present at the great defeat that ended the war.
He and another important politician by the name of anarchists actually began a
counter-revolution and they with a very small number of men.
The sources differ but the accounts that seem to be most plausible with only
seven seventy men.
They went from Thebes to a natural fortress in the mountains between Thebes
between the OCA and Attica a place called finally and build the fort there to
which they hoped.
Other discontented Athenians would flee and join them in the resistance.
And I'm using the word resistance and it brings to mind of course an analogy
that has always struck me as helpful in comprehending the situation confronting
the Athenians at this time.
To my mind it is helpful to think about France in June of 1940 after the Germans
had defeated France and occupied part of it and left the other part unoccupied
but absolutely beholden to the Nazi regime.
Now a Frenchman had three choices and just as the Athenians did.
One possibility would be to join up with the new regime and try to prosper as
part of it.
And some Athenians did that.
Others
would do whatever has to be listed and in the France it was the goal.
Who did this.
Who happened to be in London at the time this happened then he began to organize
to undo what had happened and to throw the Germans out.
It established the Free French Forces.
It's important to realize that after the war was over it's amazing how large
that Free French force had grown in people's minds.
In reality it was a handful of people.
And that's the way it always is and that's the way it was in Athens as well.
It was a terrifying prospect to tackle this regime which looked like it was
unbeatable.
Remember they had been put in place by the Spartans the Spartans ruled the
world.
What in what could what can anybody expect to change that situation.
Just as the Nazis looked like they were in business for the thousand years that
Hitler had claimed he was going to have it so that it didn't look like you were
a very courageous man.
If you joined the goal.
I don't know how many how many have you seen Casablanca.
At least you've seen one movie in your life.
That's great.
But you remember what.
What are Claude Rains and Bogie doing at the end of the war when he says Louis I
think this is the beginning of a beautiful friendship.
When he says that they're going to press avail to join the Free French.
Well great.
But what what did people think about to go.
They thought he was a god damn fool.
There was no chance.
This was idiocy.
Sensible men what are they trying to do.
They tried to win as much as they could in collaborating with the Germans to to
make their the fate of the Frenchman less hard and to help France in the future
in that way.
That's the way it was with most Athenians most Frenchmen and most Athenians
didn't do either of those things.
They kept their heads down and tried to live their lives as best they could.
And I think that's I think what you need to understand is happening and it all
puts what's Rasta bullies and amateurs and their friends did in a very special
kind of a light.
These were extraordinarily brave extraordinarily rash and extraordinarily
optimistic people.
And as it happened in this case it worked for them.
Amazingly.
They begin to gather forces that are helping them.
It's very another interesting point is that it's remarkable how few of the
people with threats of bullies were actually Athenian citizens.
A surprising number of them were permanent resident aliens medics who of course
were great targets for the 30 because they were typically well-off and had
money.
And of course they had no rights and no power.
So many of them most.
Most of the medics were certainly on the Democratic side of this argument.
Many of them went to fight others like Lizzy as the orator used his money to
hire mercenary soldiers to fight for the threats of bullies.
Democrats as well.
Well the first test came in the months of January.
There were this 70 guys or so up in the fortress on finally by now the 30 were
worried enough about this nascent army to send an army of their own much bigger
to try to get them.
And it's at this point that I'm always reminded again.
Talk about analogies of
the
events of great britain in the 16th century England.
I should say really in the 16th century.
When the Spanish Armada was heading for England trying to gain control of the
island for the pope and Catholicism one thing and another and what happened was
that nature if you will or as the British thought of it maybe God intervene as
this then the Armada was coming out great wind came up and it blew the ships out
of their path and wrecked many of them.
And really the British the English fleet didn't do anywhere near as much damage
to the Spanish fleet as did the winds and so from that day forward there sprang
up the legend in England of the Protestant wind which had come along to save the
new English faith against the forces of the pope.
Well if they can invent the Protestant wind I think it's OK for me to speak
about the Democratic snow that fell on finally that went good.
That's just what happened.
Big snowstorm came up and so when the forces of the 30 came after ACT THREE I
suppose they could this couldn't do it.
They just couldn't get there.
They were fought off.
They had to retreat.
And as they retreated the seventh came down after them and chased them and kill
them as they fled.
And then a certain amount of damage.
And the time the passage of time was very important because more and more
Athenians were becoming hostile to the regime that they had fallen under and
they more and more of them although again it is amazing how few actual Athenians
joined the rest of the list.
But by this time threads ceramic these had come into the picture.
He was more and more unhappy with what was happening.
He stood up in the council and argued against critics and critics finally had
him put to death.
That was in an indication of how far the reactionary forces in the state had
come and
we might mention also that the ancient sources estimate that something like
fifteen hundred Athenians may have been killed by the thirty tyrants.
Well that's a very large percentage of the population when you think about how
many Athenians there were.
And finally that caused so many of their relatives and friends to turn against
the 30 and to join forces even if they didn't go out there and fight to be on
the side of the Democrats.
A second attack on finally taken at a later time failed.
And now suddenly threats of bullies had a large enough force.
He marched to the pirates and gained control of that.
When the 30 brought an army out to try to defeat him there he defeated.
Then they were forced to flee to looses on the north western frontier of Attica
and the Democrats were.
About in position to take control of the city.
Again the 30 words imposed by the three thousand because it was obvious they
were losers.
And now the 3000 the successor government to to the thirty appealed to Sparta
for help against this Democratic Army.
That's Rasta Bolas had put out well think about what should Sparta do and you
might have thought it would be obvious certainly what life Sandow wanted to do
is no surprise he wanted to send a big army to restore the oligarchs.
To put his own people back in power.
And of course that was fine but there were people in Sparta who didn't want to
do that.
Who saw this as an opportunity to deprive life Sander of his power and influence
and to restore a more normal situation in Sparta.
And so the Spartans did vote to send an army.
In there to deal with Rasta bullies but they did not put lice Sander at the head
of the army or even one of his people.
Instead King poor seniors was sent out to do the job well.
They met the Athenian army under threats of bullies and defeated threats of
bullies.
But they did not
try to obliterate that army or as we shall see treat them as very serious
enemies.
For one thing the Athenians again as they had in the past fought bravely and
well and inflicted serious losses on the Spartan army but also it was obvious
that parsimonious was willing to negotiate a settlement.
He wasn't insistent upon defeating the Athenians and imposing a settlement.
And so they worked out an agreement whereby a moderate group of ten would be
chosen in Athens and poor seniors and his.
And a commission sent from Sparta to sit with poor seniors sat down with these
Athenians and worked out a reconciliation for the future.
And here is the essence of what was worked out a very important part of the
story was that they voted the Athenians did and pesetas of course would've
insisted on it to an amnesty whereby there would be no punishment for people on
one side or the other of the quarrel in Athens of course the people who would
have been punished would have been oligarchs and their friends who were now the
losing side.
There would be an amnesty for anybody no matter what except for the 30
themselves.
The Ten that the thirty had put in charge of the pie pioneers the eleven the
eleven worthy the police force so to speak the head of the security forces in
Athens and so on.
Small groups of people who were thought to be especially responsible for the
nasty things that had happened in Athens.
But even they were not summarily put to death.
They could submit their accounts at an A you soon I and.
And if they were cleared at these jury trials or things that I shouldn't call
them jury trials tribunals really.
They could take up their position as citizens in the new Athens as well or they
could be allowed freely to leave Athens without any harm.
So it was a very moderate conclusion.
What about real oligarchs.
What about them.
Well they even they were taken care of the town of a loosies which they had
seized for their own protection.
As things were going badly they were allowed to stay there after the settlement
now that left thoracic bullies and his friends in control in Athens and they
immediately reinstated the democratic constitution pretty much as it had been
before.
All of this had happened.
Briefly in this period of transition citizenship was limited to the top three
Salonen classes but that quickly fell through and really the full democracy was
restored in the year 400 and 1 in the same year the Democrats seized a looses
and brought that back into Attica.
So if you're there in the air 400 Athens would be seemed to be exactly as it had
been internally before the defeat in the Peloponnesian War.
And that newly restored democracy behaved with remarkable moderation.
Aristotle in this Constitution of the Athenians goes out of his way to praise
this successor Athenian regime.
They kept closely to the amnesty.
They did not in fact prosecute people that they should not have done.
On the other hand they and some.
And Aristotle praises this too because he also is I guess his sympathies are
very close to those of remedies
to moderate oligarchy or what Aristotle would call polity a.
Moderate regime.
When thoracic bullies ask this is an amazing thing when he ask that those people
who had served in his army who had liberated Athens and restored the democracy
that these people be granted Athenian citizenship the Athenian people voted no.
To me that is one of the most striking evidences of how the Greeks really felt
about their polls because even in a situation like that the idea of sharing
citizenship with anybody who was not so to speak a member of the family was
beyond what they would contemplate.
And even with Raza bullies the great hero the great liberator asking them to do
it they said no dice.
They also repaid the debts that the 30 had accumulated.
What they were doing of course was trying to get things calm as fast as they
could to achieve stability.
It's a very rare thing.
Imagine.
Well think of what the French did when the war was over.
They took their collaborators they tried them and they killed them.
For the most part that's that's what civilized people do.
I mean look what they did in Rwanda and other places like that where different
sides in a civil war simply butcher each other.
That's a very normal situation.
What do you think as it was very abnormal.
It was evidence I think in part of a great deal of wisdom on the part of the key
leaders at the time.
And I think it also shows you that Athens over the many years of its democracy
had not had sharp edges between the classes.
I think there was a general kind of good feeling that made that sort of mass
execution something that seemed foreign and to undesirable
so if we look at Athens and in for a one that democracy has been completely
restored.
And I'd like to draw my comments about this to close by focusing on threats of
bullies.
A man who I think probably none of you had ever heard his name when you came
into this class you'd heard of Pericles please you may have heard of the mystic
leads to lots of different things.
You never heard of surrounds the bullets so you might be surprised to hear the
following.
Cornelius Naples a Roman historian of the 1st century B.C. writing lives of
famous Greeks and Romans wrote the following about threats of Charles if
excellence were to be weighed by itself.
Apart from luck.
I believe I would rank this man.
First of all this much is certain.
I put no one ahead of him in sense of honor steadfastness greatness of soul and
love of country any better.
But it's not the end.
A few years before one hundred and eighty A.D. parsimonious the great travel
writer of antiquity wrote his guide to the famous and historic places of ancient
Greece.
In the section on Athens he described the graves of the heroes and men that
lined the roads outside the city beginning with the one leading to the place
known as the Academy.
Here's what Paul saying is the travel writer says.
The first.
Is that of threats to bolus son of life lifeless in every way.
The greatest of all famous Athenians whether they lived before or after him.
Think of all the names that are involved in the and maybe the weights of course
Amos is general comparison is intensified by something a little bit more
specific because the next words in poor seniors account is Are these his is the
first grave and after it comes that of Pericles just in case you thought he
missed Pericles by mistake.
Now that's extraordinary.
And it is a great puzzle that I've never.
I can't solve and probably never can be solved.
But.
How could it be that these fellows who lived centuries afterwards said these
things about threats of bullies and we never heard of them.
I mean barely heard of him.
I mean the best answer I can give you is there must have been lost history's and
we know there are of the period and they must have given threats the bull was
the kind of credit for their his remarkable achievements that don't show up in
Xenophon and diverse and the orators.
But we at last.
And you have an obligation to future generations must not let the name of
thoracic bolus lie in obscurity again.
And just so that you don't forget him.
Remember he.
He is the only Greek I know whose whose name fits a Yale fight song irascible
love is possible those.